see your character first you know over
the next couple years because what men
do we get so excited about a fine female
we move at warp speed super work you
know we're buying cars we're buying
jewelry
two months later you find out the
character is horrible and you really
have to take your time I tell men all
the time believe it or not the girl you
meet that day
30 days listen to when you're talking on
the phone hear how she's talking to
different people in the background and
she got kids and she put up on God damn
this thing I told you put the [__]
you heard me listen to when she talk is
a alarm detector going off so she was
too lazy to change the battery
[Music]
and then every time you call
still going on yeah and then a person
actually said oh that's been going on
for a few months and then your mind
you're like that's not the girl I want
to be with right if you that lady